ですね今日は
島根県を拠点に音楽活動をしています冷えたです
シンガーソングライターという
ただ機で
きました
シンガーソングライターっていうのは自分で曲を作って
寿命だったり
彼に歌ってもらったり
なんですけども
三脚
操作してもらいたいと思います
最初の結構
今まで作った曲の中で
一番新しい
しています
学説もたくさん来てくださってて
もし何か迷ったり
になったりすることがあったら
音楽の力ってすごく大きいと思うので
そしても
寄り添いれたらなと思います
神様との約束という曲聴いてくださいん
[音楽]
君の手の雛には
世界はを使ううちからない
つながってくる
いいのはー
ああああああ
踊り出した
[音楽]
つながってい
何
思いを超え利乗せて a
[音楽]
3かすんだ君に届くようごに
かめへの
[音楽]
私0
うわ子を張れ
me
いたん
またああ
sai
パパあぁっ
いうように
浦和行けいる
壁の向こう側えーっ
[音楽]
戸惑いも苦しみにも
恐れられない痛みの
全米
丸め
寝ちまった
[音楽]
かわああ
入ったいというものは
でもん
と板
世界中部の愛すべき人たちが
穏やかな左に
生まれます
水要望に
私位
枠おこう
[音楽]
ん
dai
バッハかけるように
僕らは行ける
そんなたヴェノム顔
小川浦和行ける
描いた夢の先へ
[音楽]
枝の先
上沢の
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
今の41歳デー
どもも3人いるんですけども
だが県外の大学を卒業して
に帰ってきて
会社勤めを7年間してました
2つ仕事をやってたんですけども
おりその仕事を
ている中で
どうしても日曜日の夕方になるとこうだんだん元気がなくなる自分がいて
また月曜日が始まるというのですね
そんな姿を
おったちがですね
見たときに果たして子どもたちはこんな大人を見って大人になりたいと思うんだろうか
っていう風に
を止めないと始まらないと思って会社員を辞めて
農学
やっていこうという風に
中です
さっきはの瑕疵のある歌を行く
トメだったんですけども
次は歌詞のない曲を
演奏します
音楽って
記憶を閉じ込める力があると思っていて
といえばです
懐かしい昔よく聴いていた曲がラジオから流れると
昔の思い出を多分思い出したりする方もいらっしゃると思うんですけども
音楽はそういう自分の名が大切な場所原点にすぐ連れて帰ってくれるもんだなぁと思っ
ていて
言葉がないことで伝わる
曲で伝わることもあるんだなぁと思っ
ハモニカで作った曲があります
ハックルベリーというタイトルがつい
た故郷
して大切な
も立ち家族のことをすぐ思い出せるように
の思いで生まれた曲を
みなさんもよかったら
された場所のことや
大切な人を想いながら聞いてもらえたら嬉しいです
[音楽]
ありがとうございました